occasionally occasionally we can push
back on these guys
and it's it's not always going to be
successful sometimes it is though
candace owens just got this actually
candace owens made the perfectly
accurate statement
the other day on facebook that joe biden
is not the president-elect
i've made this statement too people
excoriate me for it is simply a fact
that joe biden is not
the president-elect well she was
censored
she was called a liar by politifact
politifact the objective
neutral probably center-right
fact-checking right now it's left-wing
why did they call her a liar i don't
know because they said
the media called the race and it looks
like he's going to get all these votes
candace did not just roll over candace
lawyered up
threatened to sue them and politifact
offered a rare correction
she offered this correct they offered
this question they said whoopsie daisy
we've gone back and looked and said oh
yes we've now corrected this okay
well this is important because these
fact-checking websites quote-unquote
left-wing websites like like politifact
are involved
in determining what gets censored on
social media platforms
so social media platforms pretend that
they've got these neutral
fact checkers who are you know and they
throw their hands up in the air
but no they partner with these left-wing
organizations and so we've got to push
back
and you know what if you push back
against them you are going to fail
not just nine out of 10 times you're
probably going to fail 99 out of 100
times
but if you just keep it up eventually
eventually you might succeed
[Music]
you